get them all oh my God no I can't touch
this Blood Gorge mucus act I was in the
jungles of Lao one time and there were
leeches that were that big and I've had
some that were on me that were about 8
in long I'm Hazen Odell currently I have
a show called Primal Survivor on
National Geographic in Disney plus I've
been practicing Bushcraft outdoor
survival for over 30 years now today
we're going to be looking at jungle
survival scenes in movies and judge how
real they are
keep your arms above the surface when
the kid comes back grab on that could
happen about that that fast when I was
watching them sink that can be realistic
it just depends on the viscosity of the
of the quick mud or the quick sand the
deeper and thicker it is the more you
suck into it and it's harder to get out
you're going to need your hands to try
to swim out or use them to try to pull
yourself out of the
sand if they were to just p pull you out
without you moving your legs it almost
gets worse there's more suction so what
you want to do is sort of swim and
wiggle your legs to try to move around
that that Matrix of water mud and grit
and try to get it to turn into a slushie
so it'll pull you out by asking for
assistance that was a good thing so
that's why I at least give it a
three PIR better eat them before they
eat you that is the great thing about
piranhas They are an abundant fish and
they're very easy to catch cuz you just
need some sort of a meat source and then
a hook and that's you generally the
first thing you're going to catch
catching a piranha with a net is pretty
slim but there's a lot of catfish and
other kinds of fish that are really
sluggish the thing about piranhas and
piranha behavior is that they kind of
read off of each other's Behavior so if
one fish gets really excited takes a
bite there's blood in the water there's
that scent in the water it'll start
exciting other fish and pretty soon it
starts to become a chain reaction
there's well over 20 different species
of piranha in the Amazon all specialists
in eating different ways but the most
dangerous one are the red belly piranhas
and which is probably what they're
trying to depict here that is fair
Fairly realistic it would start as one
piran and then it would be hundreds of
piranha you'd get the out of that water
that's for sure I would this clip as a
seven you have to kind of look at the
probability of this happening that sort
of almost wife's tale of you being
devoured by piranha and water it it's
just incredibly
remote when you talk about the Amazon
it's such a vast area there's a lot of
scenarios a lot of different kinds of
rivers but there are certainly rivers
that are like that and really muddy like
that too and Rocky that have uh that
would be really difficult to navigate I
could see that the watercraft that they
had built was out of necessity the thing
to keep in mind is when you build a
watercraft like that they do float but
they can still weigh hundreds if not
thousands of pounds so they're by no
means
[Applause]
agile how that raft hit the rock was
very realistic wrapping around the rock
that's a really dangerous scenario if
that was your last Stitch effort to
avoid going off a big waterfall or going
through some Rapids that you knew you
wouldn't be able to survive that's what
you would have to do they were lucky in
that when that raft hit they were on the
back side of the raft a lot of times
usually the raft will go like this and
then the water will push it this way
you're on this way so you're between the
Rock and the raft with all that Raging
Water pressing against and then you
drowned or you get crushed to death it
helps out if you were experienced and
you knew what you were doing doing and
if you were purposeful about it they
probably did the right
thing you're not ever going to be able
to swim against the current you just
have to understand the Rapids understand
the Eddy lines and try to get to shore
the best you can understanding that
you're still going to get swept down the
current I was a professional Whitewater
guide for many years so that was all
power for the course
well the biggest killer out there when
you're out in a survival situation
number one killer is exposure but
another big killer is just by getting
yourself in trouble and injuring
yourself and dying of trauma so when you
when you do things like for example
climb a big tree you fall out of the
tree you're going to get damaged and
hurt so if you can if you can shake the
fruit off of a tree if you can get a big
Branch or a rock and try to hit the
fruit out of the tree and have it go
safely to the ground that's your best
bet sometimes that's not always the
scenario and if you're desperate for
food um you take desperate
measures the reason why I love the
Amazon is every single nook and cranny
has something living in it I'm a guy
that loves snakes I'm a little bit of a
sicko I can usually tell right away what
kind kind of snake it is and if it poses
a danger they were showing it as
aggressive it was striking but it was a
python so it wasn't going to pose any
danger if it was a poisonous snake like
maybe a fertiland or something you just
want to stay the out of the out of its
uh striking range for sure everything I
saw was very plausible I could
understand why they were doing what they
were doing I would rate this clip as a
[Music]
traps a very common way of bringing meat
to the table in remote areas especially
in the jungle there's so many animals
around so many different options of
things to
catch to make a trap as effective as it
could be it needs to be very well hidden
just like you see there in that
clip I have seen traps where it's going
to take multiple people to be able to BR
bend down a branch or a tree that's a
rare scenario because they're going to
be wanting to be catching something
pretty big the size of a cow a tapier
something like
that the thing about trapping is you
have to know where to set the Trap you
have to know animal behavior you have to
know the species that are around and
then you develop a trap based on what
you're trying to catch once you get the
animal stuck in the TR trap you have to
make sure the animal's going to stay
there until you get there I didn't see
all the details of this trap but I would
give it a
seven in the modern world they try to
stay away from sort of any kind of wild
water everybody seems to be really
scared of it but in a desperate
situation like that you're trying to get
any little bits of water as you can this
is pretty realistic based on uh for
example remote islands like that are out
in the South Pacific the only fresh
water is water that's been collecting on
leaves from the Dew or rain and that is
the only place where you're going to be
able to get water so In that clip that
was that was a very realistic
scenario and to collect it in a vessel
like a coconut is a very realistic
scenario there's actually thousands of
people that live in this sort of same
environment indigenous people that have
no fresh groundwater so they're totally
reliant on water that's collecting on
from Dew on leaves and also rainwater I
have two very good friends that were the
survival expert Consultants on this film
So based on their expertise and
experience they implemented it into this
film this clip is the strongest clip
I've seen as far as realism and I rate
this
clip a 10
yeah okay uh I actually like seeing that
clip because it brings back good old
memories I have been in scenarios where
I've gone through water where I wasn't
thinking that there were leeches and had
leeches that same size on me I was in
the jungles of Lao one time and there
were leeches that were that big I've had
some that were on me that were about 8
in long no what is that scream stop give
me the jumpsuit them off I don't I don't
know if you wear tighter clothes it
would be difficult to have a leech
because the leech really has to make
contact with your skin leeches have sort
of a of a three-part tooth system so it
has to be able to get onto that latch
onto your skin make skin contact and
then uh dig those three teeth into your
skin they have a saliva that makes it so
you can't feel what they're doing don't
make that
sound kinding of like picking anchovies
off my Caesar salad really a righty
tighty lefty Loosey and give her a hard
tug Once you pull them off it is truly a
just a bloody mess and sometimes you'll
be bleeding for um half the day
afterwards after a good big leech bite
like that that is a 10 that is very
possible those those were very realistic
looking
leeches to make a parachute work you're
pretty well strapped in you're usually
going to stay suspended up in the
branches and then you have to cut your
way or unbuckle yourself
out a lot of trees plants shrubs are
trying to protect themselves from being
eaten so they have thorns barbs being
snagged by little thorns and big thorns
is sometimes a daily
event
you want to leave it in place and try to
get medical attention if you don't have
anybody there to help you and you're not
going to be able to get medical
attention for weeks maybe you're
probably going to have to do something
about that and get it out of you you got
to kind of look at it like pulling the
plug and then you can bleed to death
coming out of that puncture wound so I
think she'd be even in more pain than
what is portrayed sir I think it'd be a
stretch to give it a
three you got a good pair of walking
shoes during during the wet season it'll
rain like that every day it depends
on where you're at in the Amazon it can
range anywhere from about 3 months to 6
months generally you
mudslides and landslides are very
frequent in the jungle anywhere where
there's a big slope like that there's so
much rain like that that the land just
gives way I've been closest to this sort
of scenario just by being on big roads
and then having the road washed away
actually I have a big scar in my leg
from a big rock slide which was a kind
of a landslide more than likely you're
going to at least get pretty cut up I
give this clip of
[Music]
five
before humans figured out a way to make
steel and and copper and metal their
only cutting implements were from bone
teeth and sharp rocks so those they look
like Vines but they're actually Roots a
lot of people it's kind of a
misnomer when they talked about Tarzan
swinging from Vines it's actually often
times those are roots coming from
epiphytic plants that are living on top
of the branches of other trees and they
send these big long roots to go down and
get water and access the dirt down below
[Music]
if you're familiar with the rainforest
you know what works best for different
scenarios you know where the strongest
ropes and strongest roots are by how
they look it's kind of like people that
live in the city they know that that
little Toyota is not a fast car but a
Ferrari is a very fast car people can
see the rainforest like that that's just
all comes from familiarity of being
outside you recognize what a strong
piece of wood is as opposed to a rotten
[Music]
Branch so Vines and Roots if you get the
right kinds they're really strong and
make uh very quick and dirty rope just
like that this is actually grass it's
twisted and Spide together to be able to
make a really strong rope this is
another very strong
fiber that could easily support body
weight but this is bark that's peeled
off of a tree I got this out of Guyana
which is very close to the Amazon
yeah mowgly made that clip look really
easy to try to be able to get those bees
like that you could go there and kick
the hive off like that I mean you would
get stung almost to death being
unprotected like that and especially
without use of smoke so in that scenario
it was unrealistic just holding on to a
rope like
that if you did wind up getting yourself
into honey it'd be a sticky slippery
mess making it even more dangerous I
give this clip up
four using blow guns is fairly common
with a bunch of different tribes there's
poison on this tip right here in some
places it's even more common than you
using a bow and arrow probably easiest
way to think about it is like a giant
high performance spitwad the longer of a
blow gun that you have the straighter a
poison arrow is going to fly through the
air um they fly incredibly fast and also
since they're so small they can go
through leaves they can go through
branches they're a lot smaller than a
big arrow that typically gets locked up
in in leaves and branches in the canopy
so they're in some places they're the
they're the favored hun hunting
[Music]
instrument well when you're talking
about the Amazon there are thousands of
different trees plants shrubs every
single one of those has a use a lot of
them have chemical properties that can
be used not only
for as hallucinogens but also have
chemical properties that we've
incorporated into our modern medicine
I've seen
similar ritualistic plants being used
like this in Colombia
Venezuela and
Brazil no you wouldn't be able to catch
a fish this easily with a spear the best
way is to sneak up on a fish so you have
to be quiet a lot of times in a canoe
you have somebody in the back paddling
and then the Marksman the person with
the spear is out in the front you can
spear them while they're sleeping I rate
this clip at a six my favorite scene
that I got to watch today was that scene
with Romancing the Stone because I
remember that as a child and that only
increased my Intrigue about going to the
rainforest myself
and since I went there myself it's been
probably the most significant thing I
have going on in my life and if you like
this video why not click on to the next
one